walkabout to come with me joshing
tonight and today in a special edition
of Ready Steady Mutai we're joined by
bebe Rexha shaking those tail feathers
my celebrity gas is given the challenge
of recreating a look on my delightful
face in the space of five minutes while
I enjoy oh yeah babe the pressure is on
the pressure is real I want you to give
me the ultimate eyelet giving the eye in
the club when the five minutes start
when I say say Janice okay what's the
first step um what you do okay go for it
they your new single David West is cool
say my name yes you're gonna say your
name in the Queen's English
how would you do she's Paul's she's
waiting could you name in order your top
five songs on Spotify right now meant to
be myself and I I got you nothing one
thing I've invested Batu's meant to be
number three is say my name
number four is in the name love and five
is girls yeah he was your number one
girl crush right now you crushing on I
think he always likes atomic well she's
very ariana grande's like like I love
your short hair and she's looking better
and better every day she looks amazing
anybody on your show ever tell you to
shut up Oh miss hi
you don't understand like I am like I am
such a crazy like everything I do needs
to be great and the fact that I can't do
great right now
wait don't blink
I'm really nice guy really oh no no it
looks horrendous I'm very upset
close your eyes it's bad have you ever
given the boy and I in the club and he's
like and it's not been read properly I
mean like what do you mean oh you mean
the sex I got a sec sighs no one's ever
resisted those eyes okay
I think your Heinie's ducktail really
tell you boys what are you playing at
now I know how my makeup artist feels
because I'm always like Chinese chatty
like all my phone looking down eating
Netflix Netflix the makeup bag the same
necklace like you eighty opener right
now like eighty bathroom breaks
Yuma high maintenance this is very in
right now so I feel like we just go for
like one pink I think I usually means
like I also need my invoice like I would
let me pay you like fifty thousand i we
think what you do it yeah okay well can
you sing me a little song while I'm
doing this okay well we got like a deep
box uncle give me a belly part inspired
number Joely Joely Joely Joely
uncle this is now
shimmy-shake oh hey it was like my dolly
right here but better I just feel like
I'm gonna color this one in black so
it's like this one's black and this
one's pink
yeah it's art so basically I'm gonna
look like a play Picasso okay so I saw
you the Victoria's Secret Show babe are
you slow lady don't open your eye you
shut that down because you did that drop
to the floor and I don't even know how
you did that it's like [ __ ] dropping
you'll go to you on the dance I wish I
could've done a death trap no hoping
you're right
wait let's put fake lashes on top will I
be able to see you again after this is
basing my key question my eyelids feel
weighed down put the upper lash someday
put the other laugh so it's like you
just got back from the club I've make
sure the definition of your song I'm a
mess what with the ultimate messy night
out with you be like why don't we go on
the speaker house 30 I'm you i'll
speaker goes on yeah yeah messy wait now
that looks better than last : let me
just fix this real quick I'm really
concerned as recipients my eyeball what
is your ultimate beauty regret would you
say
coming out that j.lo has never had a
drink in her life Walt yeah she'd never
smoked she'd never drink I think anytime
you put something in your body that is
not good for you I regret any time I
injury I don't like to drink that much
actually oh my god makes me so paranoid
but my Decatur obsession needs to stop
okay let's take a look wow that is me
after a messy night out this could be
the next how'd you get your you look out
in ten Bay next 100 where you see their
daughter this kids is how you take a
messy pan zoom in on you look stunning
boys beware we are coming for you if you
want to put the glam into glamour just
like us subscribe to glamming UK's
YouTube channel for more stunning beauty
tutorials
[Music]